الابار العاجله التي توردها وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تحديدا حول 30 ضابط وجندي
اصيبوا في انفجار شاحنه المواد المتفجره
تقول اسرائيل ان هذه الشاحنه اذا بغزه قتل
فيها سته جنود اذا يرتفع عدد الجنود في 24
ساعه الذين قتلوا في غزه الى تسعه ولكننا
نتحدث عن 30 ضا
وجندي تؤكد وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
انهم اصيبوا في هذه الحادثه حسب الروايه
الاسرائيليه اذا ان هذه الحادثه هي انفجار
لشاحنه من المواد
المتفجره بغزه قتل فيها سته جنود وخمسه
اذا 11 جنديا في 24 ساعه على العموم معنا
نجوان سمري من غلاف غزه نجوان انت تتابعين
ما ما تورده وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
حول هذه الحادثه كان هنالك روايه فلسطينيه
من المقاومه ايضا حول مقتل الجنود لكن
الاعلام الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن انفجار شاحنه
كانت مخصصه لتفجير
الانفاق بالفعل هذا ما تم الاعلان عنه هذا
اليوم رسميا من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
ونشير الى انه منذ يوم امس كانت هناك
مصادر اسرائيليه تتحدث عن وقوف احداث
مختلفه في قطاع غزه سقط فيها عدد من
الجنود ما بين قتيل
وجريح ووصف بانه اليوم الاقصى خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره الماضيه على الجيش
الاسرائيلي ضمن المعارك البريه لكن هذا
اليوم عمليا تم الاعلان رسميا عن تسعه من
الجنود والضباط قتلوا في مواقع مختلفه من
قبل الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي صباح هذا
اليوم اعلن عن اربعه وفي ساعات الظهر اضيف
خمسه اخرون الى البيان الرسمي للناطق
العسكري والحديث يدور عن سته من ضباط
وجنود في سلاح الهندسه التابع لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قتلوا جراء انفجار
لشاحنه كانت تحمل ذخائر ومواد متفجره في
منطقه مخيم البريج
وانفجرت هذه الذخيره ما ادى الى مقتل سته
من الجنود والضباط ووفقا لما نشر قبل قليل
في موقع واللا العبري فانه في نفس الحادثه
اصيب 30 جنديا وضابطا بينهم ايه او جروح
عدد منهم خطيره لكن هنا يعني يستوقفنا
البيان الذي صدر ايضا قبل قليل من قبل او
ما ما نشر في موقع الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل عن اخر تحديث لعدد
الاصابات في الساعات ال
24 الماضيه وقد اضاف
27 جنديا اصيبوا في اليوم الماضي ونقلوا
الى المستشفيات وهذا التباين دائما قائم
وموجود بينما ينشره الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي عن عدد الاصابات وبين ما تنشره
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه موقع والله
يتحدث عن 30 جنديا اصيب في حادثه الانفجار
لهذه الشاحنه فقط في حادثه واحده بينما
الناطق العسكري يتحدث عن 27 اصابه مجمل
اصابات الساعات
ال4 ال الماضيه بخصوص السته الذين قتلوا
منهم اربعه من وحده تسمى وحده يهل وهي
وحده نخبه في سلاح الهندسه وتخ مختصه عاده
بعمليات خاصه الى جانب قوات من ال
الكوماندوز ولكن لم يتم التفصيل وا اعطاء
معلومات اضافيه ح حول كيف انفجرت هذه
الذخيره في الشاحنه هناك من يشير الى انها
استهدفت من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والبعض يقول انه انفجار داخلي في الذخيره
لكن هناك تحقيقات بدا يجريها الجيش
الاسرائيلي حول ما حدث في هذا الانفجار
وبطبيعه الحال اشاروا الى ان هذه المواد
المتفجره حملت في الشاحنه او نقلت في هذه
الشاحنه من اجل تفجير انفاق وبنى تحتيه في
منطقه مخيم البريج وهو ما يقوم به الجيش
الاسرائيلي ونحن نرى الكثير من مقاطع
الفيديوهات حيث تقوم قوات سلاح الهندسه
بتفخيخ وتفجير منشات ومبان وابراج وبالذات
مبان سكنيه بالعاده يقول الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي بانها بنى تابعه لحركات
المقاومه ولكن ايضا من الواضح انه يتم
بشكل ممنهج تدمير لكافه الابراج والمباني
السكنيه التي لم تتدمر بالكامل جراء
عمليات القصف ال متواصله بالاضافه الى
هؤلاء السته كانت هناك اطلاق او استهداف
لمجموعه من الجنود بصاروخ مضاد للدروع في
منطقه خان يونس قتل في هذه الحادثه جنديان
وايضا جندي اخر قتل في اشتباك مسلح مع
مقاومين فلسطينيين ايضا في منطقه خان يونس
هذا هذا بشان حصيله القتلى وراينا كيف ان
سياسه الجيش الاسرائيلي دائما هي النشر
المتدرج بشان عدد القتلى
والاصابات والخسائر في صفوفه وهو ما حدث
تماما هذا اليوم بعد ان كانت كافه او غ
لبيه المواقع غير الرسميه في اسرائيل قد
بدات تشير الى هذه الاحداث التي توصف
بانها الاقصى منذ بدايه ال العمليات لكن
من جهه اخرى يعني من الواضح بان ما تقدمه
او ما تنشره ايضا قوائم المستشفيات ووسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه بشان الجرحى
والاصابات التي تصل من بين الجنود الذين
يصابون في ارض المعركه هي اكبر بكثير من
مما ينشره الجيش الاسرائيلي يوم امس كان
هناك تقرير ل صادر تحديدا عن ما يعرف
بالوحده الطبيه في الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
تم تقديم علاج نفسي ل 9000 جندي منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب وهذا لا
يشمل السكان ممن ايضا طلبوا ال العنايه
والعلاج النفسي بعد احداث السابع من
اكتوبر